do you remember when we all had to uh
stop the spread and stay at home
well i tell you one of the uh unexpected
positive things to come out of that time
well other than the
normalization of comfortable clothing in
public obviously
was that
my industry digital art and immersive
entertainment experienced a huge surge
of interest
more folks than ever before turned to
their screens
to seek out digital experiences
and online connection and uh
or social connection in online spaces
we couldn't connect in person so
suddenly our digital lives took on a
whole new level of importance
this sudden global demand accelerated
the research and development of a
previously sci-fi concept known as
the metaverse
in the metaverse we will connect with
one another as virtual avatars we will
live work and play together building a
whole new magical dimension of existence
sounds like a dream right well
technically it's a programmer's
nightmare
but if we can pull it off
it will become the world's largest
community-driven digital well-building
experiment
to date
we don't want to
sit inside staring at our screens
anymore at least i don't i love my
digital art but i want to take it with
me out into the real world so let's do
that
this is never lonely boy he's sitting in
the abandoned lot by himself until he's
surrounded by his virtual friends
now what if those virtual friends could
join me here on the ted stage
and oh bam
hey little buddies
now ideally we'd all be wearing
augmented reality glasses but
consumer-ready ar glasses not quite
there yet but this is kind of cool but
how can we uh build on this you know
what's next
and is there a way
for the digital experiences that we
create
to truly enrich our physical lives
so today i'll propose three pillars for
what i think
will help us build a healthy metaverse
starting off with pillar number one
community
so back in 2010 i had a very enriching
experience when i got to collaborate
with a bunch of geniuses
in the pilbara desert in northern
western australia me
the love punks
so we went about our digital
well-building in a very analog way
we got dressed up we put on face paint
we built sets and then we brainstormed
our stories by acting them out
now what blew my mind
was how invested these young people
became in their digital identities and
their digital world building that it
motivated them to show up every single
day for two years to learn how to colour
themselves in the comic and animate
themselves in the video game
now the love clunks began as a
collaboration with a community of around
40 people and five grandmas
there was
grandmas they were the wildest punks
and in australia
they went on to inspire a live action tv
series and a national curriculum
teaching young australians how to become
love punks
it's not bad for a bunch of funks
so that experience highlighted to me how
the digital worlds we build can be a
wonderful playground for exploring
identity for learning new skills for
practicing creativity and bringing our
communities together
and that brings us to pillar number two
technology and more specifically access
to technology we need to ensure everyone
can participate in this future metaverse
so around the same time as love punks
i began imagining how to scale these
digital well-building ideas
in my cyberpunk web comic called knowles
now i imagined
like a future digital culture where the
youth had chips in their head that
allowed them to project their art and
imagination onto a shared digital layer
that covered themselves in the city
so like
they could uh hang out at the club
wearing their virtual fashion
or they could
get chased down the street by some crazy
digital technical things that got pretty
weird
that uh digital culture would be
described today as an augmented reality
metaverse
now we're probably not all ready to get
chips in our heads but thankfully we can
access augmented reality on our mobile
devices
so
one day
i received a mysterious comment on that
web comic it read
we could make some of those things very
mysterious so i clicked on the user
profile and discovered that person was
an augmented reality programmer so i
messaged them back immediately
yes let's make all the things
that person lucas carlock is now my
business partner and we augmented
everything i went to reality comics i
went to reality tattoos stickers uh
there's a cute little turtle
uh kids could color in their own kites
and then fly them immediately as
augmented reality kites i even are
hacked the new york times that was a
little controversial and
we had a lot of artists reaching out to
us asking uh
how we were doing it so we created tools
to allow them to augment their work and
very quickly we had a community of
artists covering the world with their
augmented art it was beautiful i felt
like my vision was finally starting to
make some traction
but up until now all the experiences
that i've shared have been standalone
for example
i love punk's avatar can't like step out
of the video game and then suddenly
appear walking down the street beside
you in augmented reality like that
digital bridge doesn't exist yet
but what if it did
and this brings me to my third pillar
decentralization
so for us to move seamlessly through the
metaverse we need for our art and our
avatars to be decentralized we can't be
dependent on a single platform sorry
zuck
and
i mean what if that platform were to die
we don't want to lose our art
so nfts another word that's been flying
around a lot lately help us to solve
this problem
nfts are unique decentralized digital
assets and they've also come to
represent a new economy that has been
widely accepted as the norm for buying
and selling digital art so not only can
nfts move from one platform to the next
but they can be sold and digital artists
can get paid
and that all helps to keep the lights on
in the middle verse
so lately i've been kicking the wheels
on my own metaverse
called the sutu verse
very humble
and
my first project in the pseudo-earth is
neons
i uh illustrated hundreds of cyberpunk
characteristics like virtual reality
headsets and face tattoos and antennas
then we created a tool to combine all
these characteristics together to
generate 10 000 unique avatars as nft
artworks
we then put those nft artworks up on the
environmentally friendly tezos
blockchain
thousands of fellow cyberpunk
enthusiasts collected them thank you
we then connected our augmented reality
app to that blockchain to allow our
community to become their neons in ar
and look at us
we're like a cyberpunk brady bunch
and just imagine again when we have
those augmented reality glasses and we
can just see each other down the pub
like this like that'll be one hell of a
neon's reunion
and look if you're not interested in the
theatrics or put neons on your face
that's cool
because you can also put your neons
floating out there in the physical world
so there's some neons down in the snow
neons down the beach neons floating
above an oblivious cat
and if you're not interested in the
neons aesthetic that's fine too because
soon you'll be able to put any digital
art you've created or collected floating
out there in the physical world
so
i feel like
our love punks community and our neons
community are totally ready for this
future
but how are you folks feeling
are you ready for this brave new digital
world
not sure
well this is just the beginning you
could leave a digital artwork on the
street corner for your lover to find
you could reinvent your backyard with an
animated treasure hunt for your kids and
their friends
we could use this tool to simply cover
the world
or we could use it
to further connect us to this world i'm
interested in the latter
how can we use this powerful tool to
create an augmented reality metaverse
that truly enriches our physical lives
thank you